vous avez sûrement vu passer une de ses
publications qui relativise l'impact de
lakovic 19 et toujours cette question
est ce qu'on est allé trop loin pour une
maladie finalement pas si mortel plus au
mois d'avril chaque semaine et plus de
décès par que vite que de décès par
cancer du sein ou par cancer du poumon
donc on n'est pas la face à quelque
chose qui est une petite grippette
au plus fort de la crise sanitaire on a
compté plus de 7000 morts quotidiens
dans le monde 2007 130 en moyenne selon
les derniers chiffres disponibles de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
les hépatites sont en moyenne
responsable de 3700 décès par jour
la tuberculose ses 3400 2100 pour le vih
sida et 1200 pour la malaria
mais les tableaux qui circulent mélange
souvent des choses très différentes et
pas forcément toujours simple à
comprendre qu' on ne peut pas comparer
par exemple des maladies avec des
accidents de la route
l'explication derrière la fausse
information est toujours plus compliqué
moins facile à digérer que la fausse
information qui viennent en une image
déjà très simplifié et comment
s'explique cette défiance de certains
face à la gravité de la crise en partie
parce que les discours officiels ont
beaucoup fluctué sur la question des
masques par exemple les experts change
parfois le message qu'ils transmettent
au fur et à mesure qu'ils acquièrent de
nouvelles informations
mais pour certaines personnes dans le
grand public
ça peut paraître suspect est donc miné
leur confiance à reverser d'expérience
et puis il y à la question du taux de
mortalité
impossible de l'établir avec précision
tant que la pandémie n'est pas terminée
mais les épidémiologistes s'entendent
sur une approximation ce que l'on voit
comme mortalité d'une mortalité qui
ressemble un peu à la pandémie de grippe
de la grippe espagnole de 1918 qui
devait être entre 1 et 2 % de mortalité
ça paraît pas beaucoup en fait cet
effrayant car une mortalité de 1% pour
une maladie qui a un potentiel de toad
attaque c'est à dire d'infection de la
population extrêmement grand c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
inquiétant
environ 1 % de mortalité et la grippe
saisonnière alors si on prend juste
l'exemple des états unis lé 10 à 15 fois
moins mortel ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal